c'est ma collection il y a toutes sortes
de restes et de choses qui sont écrites sur
les choses de l'hôtel chaque fois que je démarre un
projet et je m'assieds ici comme ça et je
regarde à la maison n'aime pas que
tout le monde n'ait pas la capacité de rester et
tout le monde a la ténacité  et
tout le monde n'a pas tant de choses à dire êtes-vous
dans le domaine du divertissement ouais quelle était
la chose la plus misérable de votre
enfance probablement le fait que j'étais
jeune
j'ai apporté ça sur nos 16 ans fonctionne toujours
comme un tank et c'est une machine à écrire allemande
le gars  m'a dit que ce serait là longtemps
après ma mort que faites-vous quand vous
devez couper dans les affaires mais quand j'arrive
à un joli pot je coupe cette partie et l'
agrafe dessus c'est très primitif je sais
mais ça marche très bien pour moi  saviez-vous
que je viens d'avoir un gros coup de cœur il n'est pas
tout à fait tombé amoureux de moi mais j'étais
souvent là et nous avons fait une bonne équipe il a écrit certains des meilleurs personnages féminins de tous les temps ma relation
avec la mort reste la même  je suis fortement
contre  la quantité de longévité est une
réussite mais pas la plus précieuse la
réalisation que je vise est d'essayer
de faire un grand film qui m'a échappé au
fil des décennies
vous